hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and I'm John
so it's December 10th still don't have
that access to the channel plenty of
things are dropped oh yeah nothing like
being behind nothing like being behind
when you've got no choice but to be BA
ready player one trailer drop today we
got check it out and we'll decide later
what we're putting this video up right
now just want to say a quick thank you
to the real rejects video sponsor
Stardust started roughly regularly there
right now so follow us there down the
link and follow us first and today's
patient the day shots gonna go out to
Adelia change decided to show you out my
dear
anyway let's watch this trailer first my
name is Wade wise I don't take that name
because it sounded like a superhero's
alter-ego I got Peter Parker or Bruce
Banner but he died when I was a kid my
mom too ended up here
my tiny corner of nowhere there's
nowhere left to go nowhere except the
Oasis yeah I got read this book Wow
[Music]
the Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday oh if you're watching this I'm
dead hidden-object an easter egg the
first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars whoa
there's a real plot here
[Music]
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
much bigger than just
[Music]
gone dumb
ya know that last to inside it super
smooth was that that's right
eateat or something right which part oh
yeah yeah et sounds its sound it's it's
a familiar sound it's one Spielberg
movie maybe that's just his sound you
know like when you turn on your computer
and it makes like oh yeah I've know it
sound that's just the spiel brace I mean
the movie looks really cool it looks
really enticing and in a lot of ways
looks like a really cool adventure flick
and a day and age where CGI seems to be
talked about more when it's bad fit as
opposed to what it's good this is that
movie that can get away with whatever
CGI is specifically because it's a
virgin videogame yeah it's a it's them
locking into a virtual reality world now
I don't know how much people will be
able to get on board for that do they
really want to sit through a half real
life half animated movie because it
seems like that's really what it'll be
it feel like it's gonna be split between
this is real life because I feel like
any time in the virtual reality world
whatever the CGI is and we're gonna be
on board with it because it's a virtual
reality yeah
the times where that's a good conceit
question the CGI will be when it's in
the real world then you have CGI
background stuff yeah I mean this
definitely looks thrilling I almost feel
like now it's it's which references are
gonna be left out yeah yeah yeah I mean
this trailer even more than the last it
feels like you know they're they're
going hog-wild on this it's 20 45 and
it's all a bunch of 80s reference yeah a
bunch of like sinister looking adults
trying to outwit kids yeah yeah like you
guys are gonna win but I like that plot
it's kind of got this Willy Wonka plot
about it you know it's like Willy Wonka
meets the reverse matrix yeah we want to
be in the in the computer now I got to
find the keys to inherit the kingdom
oMG Terpening over at patron has
suggested to us many times that we read
the book and I want to read the book at
the same time though Spielberg's known
for kind of a string away from the book
and doing his own thing when it comes to
adaptations other than reading the book
because it's a great book I would only
read it to prep myself for the movie
that would be a decent topic of
conversation because especially with how
beloved that book is I'm yeah or the
side-by-side compares
they're gonna run run wild and I'm sure
a lot of people will have that because
not every book that comes out of a movie
you know it's hit or miss as to whether
everyone's right you're like this one a
lot of people will have read it and also
for movies based off books when we get
trailers that are all about spectacle
yeah I can kind of deter me away cuz
that always gets I know no book is
popular because of big action sequences
that are describing it they're popular
because of the characters and the
journey in the story no matter whatever
the book is that's something that ready
player one trailers haven't really given
me enough of yet I've get I keep in a
lot of spectacle and how cool this world
is but I don't really care too much
about the main guy the story inside of
it just looks like a story I've seen a
lot of times yeah it's like yeah you got
this main guy in an apocalyptic future
and he's just doing you know whatever to
get by but eventually he's gonna get
wrapped up in some kind of shadowy
corporate corporate dudes ben mendelsohn
it's Hunger Games Maze Runner it's a
young adult novel yeah yeah and and this
trailer at least isn't giving and
neither did the first one give me much
to really latch on to in terms of yes
story and character but it's so I feel
like you'll have that III doubt it'll
only be that especially if it's silver
I'm interested to see what he brings to
this part of the arena cuz the last
movie he directed was another book
adaptation but of like a children's
classic and now this is more of a you
know young adult now so just anybody who
cares even remotely about the a yeah
yeah so it is a different vibe and a
different demo I'm interested to see him
do something so spectacle heavy again
well I'm excited for it I mean we're
definitely gonna be watching it the day
comes out so we'll be there we'll be
there patron of the day shout out to
Adelia Chamberlain dealio
Adelia has been a longtime follower of
the channel she is one of her most
interactive patrons we've ever had and I
Delia is such a sweet sweet lady I mean
we've message each other back and forth
on patreon the more I get to know her
the closer I feel to this woman she's a
brave soul even though sometimes she
doesn't feel the most confident in
herself I'm telling you guys this woman
is super intellectual she's very
articulate it has its own efficient way
of communicating with her work even like
did this audio log type of
Podcast and she's a huge Star Wars fan
and it's a bummer because on the 12th
she has to get foot surgery so she's not
gonna be able to go to the theaters for
a while she's gonna have to avoid the
internet to avoid any and all glass Jedi
spoilers I want you to know it Delia I
have faith you can avoid all concealers
okay kylo Ren dies
haven't seen the movie yet but I already
heard this Han Solo comes back love you
and be safe
surgery you're a beautiful woman and you
deserve to have a healthy foot subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell you can follow us on
patreon it's become like our second
channel slash website so go check it out
and make sure to download and follow us
first on the stardust app people posting
regularly on there and follow a daily on
star those tissues on stardust else
hella star does